you
[Music]
it's good morning everyone so this panel
topic is very close to my heart so you
know for the following reason that at
some point of time in future I want to
actually build a product where we can
get companies to share really private
data with each other sometimes even
competing companies to share private
data with each other and collaboratively
fight against financial crime right so
I've worked in the financial crime
industry for like a long time now and
often I see that third-party companies
which are data providers they're able to
actually collaborate with companies to
get their data and sell it back to them
but companies themselves they're never
able to collaborate with each other so
therefore you know hopefully I can get
some answers which will help me and
hopefully you guys can get some answers
which help you as well so at this point
I would like love to have all the
panelists introduce themselves starting
with you penny actually sorry but one
then also a quick request while you
introduce yourself if you could also
just tell us how did you get into the
field of either machine learning or
privacy yeah pronita become a student
and researcher at MIT I've been a
statistician from times when the data
science buzzword was not as popular as
it is today nor is the UNA was the data
engineering buzzword I'm moving into
machine learning due to working in a
startup that was founded by Tony Jabbar
a professor at Columbia and a director
of machine learning so those are the the
beginnings but currently as far as
privacy goes it's it's what I really
care about from a privacy of our AI
perspective and m/l perspective as part
of my hair my theses my research work my
dumain my bucket of problems that are
working let's all focus on distributed
ai distributed ml and that comes along
with privacy and also adjacent problems
like fairness security safety and
efficiency of algorithms from a
communication bandwidth perspective and
the computational efficiency in general
my name is Abe Gong I have always loved
human scale data and came in to tech got
pulled pretty quickly into healthcare so
I've worked at a company called massive
health little company
we got acquired by jawbone it had the
fun experience of working on consumer
wearables in the very early days there
so help them wellness data a very
personal just try to figure out what
that could do I've also worked more
deeply in the bowels of real health care
I was the chief data officer at a
company called aspire health that did
palliative care for really sick patients
in their home so I was doing data
aggregation machine learning interesting
problems they're both both on the
patient facing side and on the technical
side just in general I care a lot about
data ethics and what it means for human
beings and so I'm yep interested in
talking about how sharing data
aggregating data privacy changes how
people work together changes power
relationships changes collaboration I'm
Erin Krishnaswamy and I work at workday
as a leaf data scientist so I've been a
mission learning guy throughout my
career I don't know anything else
actually I didn't know that but my
assume that privacy was in a previous
startup before birthday where we are
trying to do very cool things like you
know track a purse track a shopper when
they come into the store and then
combine the physical and digital
footprint of the shopper put them
together so you can already imagine all
the privacy issues there so that's my
stint there and I learned a lot about
not just how do you do data science and
stuff when you have so many constraints
of you know privacy and things like that
so
everyone a new privacy space for several
years now how I got into the space it's
pretty simple that was came in to do my
Master's for instance a long long time
ago in the area of dependable
distributed systems and then my PhD
thesis advisor had a project sponsor
recommending of that from the Air Force
Research Lab with the proposal for
research on privacy preserving data
mining and then I just saw internet it
just took something interesting and the
first paper that came up was the time
years Sweeney's paper and how she I was
able to reconstitute any plus 82 percent
if I'm not mistaken of Massachusetts
population which is public up and they
kind of got me interested and excited
enough to finish a PhD and try to see
preserving data mining techniques and
then and then I was since then I've been
in the space of security privacy happy
that gdpr is put together term of data
protection that in capsule capsule its
security and privacy together but a lot
of my work through the years over the
different companies that I've worked
with has had to do a lot with data how
do you handle data sharing across
different domains I was at Microsoft was
about like being sharing data with
office that one becomes what's private
what's not what sensitive what's not how
do you track Cortana I mean location
tracking and so on so it's been an
interesting space and an interesting
journey happy that there's a lot more
attention and happy that span the data
consulates interviews in security elida
cool so as you can see we have a lot of
incredible talent in the room at the
moment so as we proceed with the
questions I would love for people to
think about other questions you may have
that you want to ask later will reserve
like five minutes to the end for those
questions so I would love to actually
you know just start digging in so yup
like one of the the key
shoes that we faces that privacy and
data science actually often they don't
go together right so if you try to
anonymize data you can't extract value
out of it and quite often we've also
seen cases where you know any data set
which has been published to cattle or
what-have-you like even the Netflix
dataset people have been able to Dianna
Mize it right so what are some of the
approaches that you guys are seeing
either in academia or industry which
will help solve that problem so maybe we
start with you penny yeah sure so with
increasing levels of complexity beyond
anonymization because anonymization is
for the lazy or people who don't care
about it
it's too dangerous to release public
around my skated like he already put it
so ignoring that the next level would be
office keishon so by adding noise and
kind of having noisy data to the extent
that it's preserving the privacy
especially of the outlier cases so this
is basically a differential privacy and
that's a ton of work done by since
originated by Cynthia at work and she
wanted cheering cheering Award for that
so that's an active area and but the
problem there is depending on how many
queries or how many operations you do
you need to keep adding more and more
noise so your there is a dichotomy
between privacy and utility like they're
kind of try to link you can add too much
noise it's still private but it's not
useful anymore but it's a very
fast-moving area and then the next
approach in terms of complexity by
complexity I mean in terms of how secure
or protection how much protection you
get would be a federated learning that
came up by Google AI which was ahead of
its time and it came up but no one cared
about it but now everyone its kind of
its kind of really viral in a sense
within the distributed ml community and
and then split learning which is work
from our group which is which is kind of
doing what federated aim to do which is
not share raw data at all the raw data
does not leave any of the client it's
just the model related information that
is shared but split learning is
extremely drastically communication
efficient in terms of how much bandwidth
you use and in terms of compute and
memory load in the client so it can
really be roll down even down to the IOT
devices and for mobile phones where you
don't expect to run at a reson 800
because you don't have a GP on a cell
phone I things like that
so that's that and then there's the
extreme level of security which is from
the cryptographic and the theoretical
computer science community which is a
and homomorphic encryption so so in a
single line people convert the data into
ciphers just like the encryption
community does but the homomorphic
encryption creates the ciphers in such a
way that there's a parallel operation
that you could run on the cypher data so
if I want to do an addition of my raw
data I convert my router into ciphers I
send it out it's encrypted form and then
there's a very extremely severe than a
strange operation that is in parallel to
what an addition is supposed to mean in
the cipher space you applied that
operation and what results out is
another cipher and you send that back to
the client that respected that requested
the service and then when you decrypt it
you end up getting the right answer of
what the Edition is supposed to be
same thing with multiplications and all
the different circuits that are involved
in doing like training of deep learning
models but the biggest issue that
homomorphic is it doesn't scale to large
a large number of computations at all at
the most you can run
it's a fast-moving area but at the most
currently can run super simple neural
networks with very few layers and super
small datasets but only for inference
only for prediction you cannot train
with that so what I really care about is
the split learning approach which allows
you to Train
sort of federated Noora Noora which is
not done by like the office kitchen or
like the homomorphic approaches all you
could do is either basic statistics or
histograms and count queries and maybe
at the most
prediction or inference tasks but not
like a training of a model which
requires millions of computer operations
so just to summarize then would you say
that homomorphic encryption or
homomorphic computation would be useful
like 10 years from now or would that be
like it's even like very useful now it's
a very fast-moving area the problem it's
not a problem the area the community is
in some sense segregated the community
that does go morphic encryption is
extremely motivating it mathematically
and theoretically so the strengths that
they're putting in is leading to results
which are extremely security even
attacks like quantum computing attacks
and stuff like that
the ML community
is catching up so ml is not number one
in everything there's different
communities right so Emily's catching up
to bringing in security from homomorphic
so there are people that are working to
abridge this space and it's fastly
moving you never know maybe not ten
years maybe five years you'll start
training a mod models that are having
these additional tricks that are coming
of because of the abridgement that
you're getting from the practical and
the theoretical community maybe not now
and for about ten years if not more into
the ML community is interested so
community in the last two years yeah
that's right another way maybe you I
want to shift focus to today so at
birthday for instance I don't you have
this problem that you can't have
competing companies sharing the HR data
with each other yeah so how do you solve
for that problem today wish we solved
yeah okay so we are trying different
techniques and one of the technique
which you know praneeth was talking
about the split neural network could be
an option you're exploring that option
there we don't have to take so one of
the issues is like the data for our
customers is kind of locked
we don't it's a legal thing that it's
like we don't have access to that and
things like that but there are many
other techniques we are using some of it
I cannot really share because of
confidentiality and stuff but we're
trying to different techniques to solve
that problem but from a technical
perspective I think one of the first
things we wanted to try is to see you
know what's the best information we can
get an aggregated the certain extent
that we can office Kate the customer
radix 10 so they create like cohorts so
that the real
a tenant cannot be even identified or
the customers cannot be identified I'd
still make its classic data science and
segmentation and stuff is like our first
thing so that we can actually say oh we
are not you know we try to do it in such
a way that reverse engineering is not
possible this is something I actually
learned my previous startup where we
were trying to stretch data for a
specific shopper from multiple
third-party sources and we usually we
give some kind of an identification to
them and they'd they stitch the data and
give it back to us and but when they do
it they basically strip off the identity
and stuff like so they think that
they're doing a great job of you know
protecting but you could actually
reverse engineer quite easily so largely
because I know what are the techniques
we use for reverse engineering I think
we want to make sure then we do the same
thing at work day we want to just avoid
those things so it's I think pretty much
experimental to a great extent like they
try different techniques and and above
all they also have to have the legal
implications of whether that customer
would agree to what we are trying to do
I think that's a big one to people there
is a technical part to it and there's
always like this legal part when you
work with actual customers you know what
they feel about sharing that data is a
big hurdle to cross than the technical
sides yeah yeah one issue is a captain
Mary Thompson yeah I have a follow-up
question though I got a four we Devon so
like the VI understand it split learning
is an approach where at a very high
level you're trying to opt for skate the
data itself by training a neural net
right so they leave you're only the data
doesn't leave yeah all you're doing is
training as communicating partial parts
of your model so the what needs to be
learned is split the model is split
across the entities so there is a
partial learning that every entity
contributes to you and a very small
fraction of that is communicated so it's
like highly highly transformed data and
then there's additional tricks that we
do so that you cannot Rican
got it so it would be fair to say that
if I were to just use a neural net and
train it like in one tenant to train the
reader then that would not be provably
private in any case right because it's I
could just throw all data at it and then
basically learn what comes on as an
output and learn the structure of the
issues rescue buting the data is
distributed in siloed away that's the
premise right so how distribution part
actually helps with preserving the
privacy well the distribution is the
landscape the constraints are privacy so
the landscape is the data is distributed
that's the nature so I want a hospital
one to communicate with another hospital
and train a model together to do a
diagnostic of lung cancer for example
everyone has their small cooler data and
that's the nature of it and you cannot
fool them together because of the
regulation that's the landscape the
constraint is privacy and regulation
incentives to not able to share because
these are or profit could be non profit
to you and maintenance is an issue and
things like that
that's the constraints and then solution
is to split learning the whammer's of
the problems relaxed with learning
federated homomorphic so that's actually
a good segue into your work then Abe so
what is your take on privacy versus data
science specially in the healthcare
industry when you say my work I it's
almost not work yeah since I think on
this panel we have technical solutions
really well represented let me let me
just give voice to a bunch of the non
technical solutions yes I'm there
so contracts right in a b2b setting go
off and have providers or work together
and say we're gonna share data which are
only allowed to use it for X Y & Z we're
gonna audit you when you get to audits
so audit logging access logging looking
at who has looked at the data who had
access when all of those things it's
people where it's not really software
but it's how a lot of business gets done
today especially in health care got it
yeah
similar to work problems that you
already talked about it's more technical
problems I think eventually because of
the great growth and different
techniques and stuff like that what grew
but I think the contractual agreements
and things like that it's it's it's
almost impossible to find a way around
all of them so I think the uber solution
would be to combine
like you know hybrid solution of like
how do you tackle it in a legal way as
well as the technical way and then put
them together come up I said I totally
agree with that I think there's a lot of
interesting room for legal innovation
that would also tie into a data sharing
innovation but do you have more I think
an interesting part about that is I
think you alluded to it as well is that
a lot of the things that you cannot talk
about in terms of what your solutions
are think that the lack of common
standards
agreeable standards in terms of what is
like privacy I mean what can be checked
off as okay this data is private as of
this day and this is an open standard
these are ways to do it there's no one
that goes and presents and says hey
we've done this and this works because
there's so much of concern from the
legal community even though eyes and
engineer think this technique is awesome
and something that we should probably
share the the legal team would say no
way I mean we mean the the the the EU
would come behind you and they'll find
something wrong or the FTC would come
back and you did they'd find something
wrong so unless we are more open and
share what we're doing and propose
techniques and I think this it's a
hindrance for our community to go so
very one-way to say that be that you're
how do you convince a legal team that
something is probabilistically private
you want it black or white right and
it's more of some of the checkpoints
that that he mentioned as well in terms
of like provably right in terms of like
having do we have a way to audit this
that it's secure but how do you know if
you do not know what the other side
looks like how it can be used from the
other side how can I use it we do not
have good models yeah there are three
issues in terms of auditing there could
be adversarial attacks it's always a
cat-and-mouse game like you know so how
do you prove for all kinds adversarial
attacks because the auditing community
is not theoretical computer science or
math right they're coming up with
rule-based solutions what if I
so basically simple rules that large
companies follow are I cannot query
individual level data and you need
specialty permissions to be able to do
that and and the engineers are much much
smarter than those rules that's because
they're like super simple rules from
like the 80s or 60s or whatever
so the problem there is people just
write a query that is smart that comes
up with maybe 5,000 records another
query that comes up with 5,000 five
different she ate it now you do a diff
and then you just know what this fire
occurs that you care about it at the
individual level there's like I'm team
number of solutions to do the breaking
the auditing the problem with regulation
well it's not a problem the issue in the
regulatory space is regulation is always
falling behind and catching a technology
that's the nature of regulation
regulation changes much slowly
technology like people in are in the
room therefore n moves super quick like
every day there's something that's
happening so the problem is we we keep
pushing the technology but also start
trying to act and synthesize and apply
because that's when you really had faced
with regulation had face to face with
auditors and rules and what really
happens on the ground truth like you
were putting together and then come up
new solutions or things would not move
because this is like two orthogonal
spaces of people doing their own thing
that's one reason we are moving into
applying split learning in partnerships
between MIT and MGH MIT and Harvard and
those experiments are underway and these
are more like the synthesize and act
kind of situations where you come up
with real-life else as well okay only
thing which I wanna add here is because
I believe there's a more number of data
scientists in this room than legal and
other players right so from my
experience what I realized is that it's
always good to actually have the legal
understanding of why illegal talks in
certain ways because it's very difficult
as technologies to think in a very we
always trying to optimize solutions for
everything you know that's in our head
we always go for our this is the best
solution I have technically but always
be cognizant on the other side on what
the legal side is thinking about so if
you want to be successful preserve drive
privacy and actually move the things
needed in terms of you know machine
learning as well and you know in these
kind of situations you always be very
cognizant of the legal side it's very
very important
you mean in fact I go to that extent I
actually took like a Coursera course to
understand what my legal team was
talking so it helped me
because I mean they are lost in my world
and I'm lost in their world and there is
nothing can happen so it's just a you
know piece of advice from my experience
that try to understand their world as
well to some extent and it it's going to
be very beneficial you wanna add
something yeah just a couple follow-up
thoughts so one I definitely agree that
regulation is slow-moving it's one of
the reasons that I think working with
legal at the contracting level opens up
a lot of interesting possibilities
because you have companies that already
want to work together ahead of
regulation right before there's good
regulation they still have to get the
legal framework in place and so you've
got people who at least have an
incentive to make something happen to
the point about working with legal I've
actually found working with legal to be
really interesting ethnographic
experience in the sense that so as an
engineer I know that when people talk to
me they're often a little bit baffled
why X is easy and X prime is really
really hard right I've had exactly the
same experience with legal like oh if we
do it this way oh yeah no problem but if
you do that no no no that would bring
the company down and I both done exactly
the same it from an outside perspective
okey but but getting to a place where I
have a rich enough mental model of you
know what what are the suits and
countersuits that they're worried about
what's the contracting environment
they're in it it's rewarding in the
sense that like engineering you can
sometimes find clever solutions that
open up huge escapes of work and
definitely it actually makes you very
creative person I mean it's not the
technical side and then it's like you
know data science in the biological
world you know mathematically thinks of
possible and then biologically they're
not possible because there are
constraints same thing happens you know
mathematically you can solve technically
control of a problem but when you add
the legal stuff you have a lot of
constraints added Oh got it so actually
this could be a good segue into the next
topic I wanted to cover which was
security and machine learning right so
I'll start off with an example so I used
to work for coinbase a cryptocurrency
company where you know we were
essentially a security first company
which meant that my dear assigned tests
could not run anything in production
they in law of cases didn't have access
to data in production so
before we could even build machine
learning or do machine learning on data
we had to build a super secure system
where every code was actually before it
was pushed live it had to be
peer-reviewed so that no one could just
go run off anything get off a wire and
then secondly everything had to be
doubly encrypted when it was stored at
rest in disk and then in memory you have
to decrypt it so that then your machine
learning models can actually decrypt the
data and now the data scientists they
didn't have access to the keys to
decrypt the data only the code that was
running in our cloud environment had
access to the keys right so we had to go
through all this before we could
actually do machine learning I'm curious
to hear your from your personal
experiences what have you seen like
security and data science you know when
they are law at loggerheads what are
some examples you've seen not today you
want to kick that off yeah GDP are for
instance yeah so there are multiple
layers I just like we have in in this
room here we have the infrastructure
right and data scientists need access to
the raw data right at least in part I
mean initially to do some sampling to
build something to prove to prove some
concept as much as I feature and so
there's at some point of time you need
to have Justin in there and and then get
them into a secure environment the first
thing we have to do I mean wherever I've
been is I allow for that secure
environment ensure that there is that
protected environment it's a lot of data
duplication that we have to do in terms
of making that secure environment
available for them and then having
multiple layers on top right isn't like
building that pre-production the
research environment where they can
build it's completely isolated and then
stretching out with what I'm under any
news for instance in terms of when say a
model or when an algorithm is ready to
to be taken up into a production
development stage right and then that
sign-off is a process and it's just what
I've found is no matter how small or how
big the company we've had to create
these
these barriers to to agile development
just because we don't have legs clear
techniques like hey this is not built
right it's not ingrained I mean if I'm
if I'm starting out a company I want to
prove and keep going right build give it
to the people and get feedback and
continue to build and I mean so as
today's like it's always access control
layer first and then there's like levels
on top of it and then a lot of times
would we come up what we come down to is
should we build a data warehouse for
instance and that's like a problem that
if some people have the have the ability
and the manpower to to build that
weather out and others do not so you
just replicate environment from then and
then like obfuscate add noise data at
every level right and then build up
golden data sets for testing for
Diagnostics and this is not just for the
machine learning sides right and or for
the redesign side is also for when
someone has to debug an issue in
production what do you do do you give
them the keys of the kingdom to data or
is the training set enough I mean the
dues are like problems that we have to
solve for in terms of what keys they get
and what processes like it so we've
built up techniques some of which I can
talk about so I'm gonna take care but
there's a lot of crosses too involved
got it that's that's good
how do you solve for this at work trails
do you do you have access to data then
yeah yeah it's more than work that I
think I can I want to give like a
different example which I faced at our
previous sintered visa there the problem
it's like we talked about machine
learning and stuff sometimes it becomes
like a very interesting problem is
something called an insider threat
problem because so you're a data
scientist you are actually working in a
company and then you have to build a
model to basically detect insider threat
and unfortunately you're also an insider
so imagine this problem it's like so if
you have to develop so many layers so
that the there is a set of people were
called security investigators who
actually know or the people who should
knows like the problem guys and it could
be the data scientist itself
you have to develop so many techniques
to kind of be still need to use the data
but at the same time if that if that one
of the insiders threat is the person who
is actually the data scientist I cannot
identify myself there so we had to use
like it's a very different kind of a
problem than the you know other kind of
problems you guys are talking about
where you know you cannot really see the
data and see and you cannot be exposed
to it but you have to build machine
learning on it so we developed a lot of
interesting techniques again it became
unfortunately proprietary but I can
definitely talk about in private for you
some of them like what we use but those
are some of the it's a very interesting
problem from like so we have to develop
stuff where we see dashboard we cannot
really understand what it is but when
the security investigators say they know
every story again
behind it so it's kind of you know like
it goes into access control and stuff
but access control in a very different
way so I mean at work day also we have
some similar problems but I think we are
far far away from solving them but these
are is a concrete example so I thought
like anyone else wants to add anything
just a little bit of a reframing of Rupa
you said that you need trust in order to
make things happen like my mental like
rule of thumb is if you can give data
scientists access to the raw data kind
of like if you can build that kind of
trust it's worth like a 3 to 5 X speed
up against having to build walls in and
throw things back over the walls just as
a ballpark when I think about a lot of
the infrastructure you put in place for
this you can think of it as trust
augmentation infrastructure so for
example when you talk about access
logging right who looked at which data
on which times what query did they run
if you've got that in place and you have
well-meaning internal actors then it
frees them to just do their thing
because they know there's somebody's
watching they know there's an audit
trail and so they just do their thing
they don't have to worry about like
what's okay to do what's not okay to do
that's a very good point in that it's
it's just unfortunately easier said and
done depending on the use just the
access control in itself if you use a
relational database or something rather
than that's that's an easier problem but
other
it's like the layers of the stack how do
you really make into some level but this
at the end of the day that is some
amount of trust but there are every tool
needs to be built with that in mind but
I'm totally with you and I've had this
hunch that there's probably a really
good start it may be maybe this is
already exists but there's some probably
really good start up ideas to be built
around how do you scale trust within big
enterprise organizations under
regulation right and that have a highly
technical component but also just like
people process who can see what when
yeah so actually I'll switch gears a
little bit I'll pose a technical problem
that I've been thinking about for a
little while and the problem is the
following so in fin crime as well as you
know anyone working in cybersecurity
you're like if I want to see whether the
account was created by a bot versus a
human then I would take a look at the
email address and even study the do and
Engram analysis of the email address
right steady if it is you know if it
matches a person's name or is it just
randomly generated right now suppose you
know I need to now encrypt email
addresses before I can actually start
doing any such computations on it right
for sure I can't do sha-256
right you would say I can't do that
right well the compare operation even
after you do like simple things will add
additional computational overload but
then it's also gonna be organized right
like if I just did a simple sha-256 just
doing the shot 56 is not enough you want
to do additional analysis on it because
you want to do this fake fake detection
or like the detection of where the trail
of bad actors are coming in that is the
hard part
encrypting is easy like you can encrypt
anywhere in anything it's something goes
and something comes out but what you do
with the encrypted piece is the hardest
part that's the homomorphic part god but
what I was getting to was the following
which is that if I if I were to just you
know use a sha-256 then I'm still gonna
be open to leakage right and therefore
what technique can I use such that I'm
not leaking any data but at the same
time I can do n gram analysis okay so
Ingram is in a sense some sort of
counting operation but you're doing at
the pairwise Kripalu eyes level mm-hmm
it's kind of unsupervised it's on the
simpler complexity of problems so so
this can be handled so what you want to
do is you want to transform your email
into a feature which is often done in
the machine learning community but the
feature needs to have extremely low
statistical dependency or mutual
information or correlation with the
variables that you care about that you
want to hide maybe you don't want to
hide the serial number for obvious
reasons but you want to hide ethnicity
or gender or things that we care about
in the society or their healthcare
status no private records the sensitive
data field if you can transform the
email or any other input data into
features which are compressed
representations that are learned anyway
through deep learning mechanisms and
outer inverse and stuff but the thing is
they don't block the flow of information
that'll let you reconstruct back because
this is the time to do that now all they
care about is having enough information
in your compressed representation or
features that let you go forward in
predicting the labels which is great at
how the neural networks are doing right
now so you know we want to add this
additional gate in terms of making one
wave function so that's one area of work
we're trying to reduce the correlations
and a good measure of correlation or a
mutual information with respect to the
input data that is scalable then you
have these kind of guarantees and there
is a different names for this and one of
this approach we this my recent paper
that got accepted two days back so I
redid some of my slides in my talk
yesterday we call it no peak split
runnin so no peaks button and so it's a
split learning technique where whatever
you're learning is extremely lowly
correlated in terms of what you're
communicating out of one client to the
other with respect to the raw data but
it has all the information to go forward
to do the utility of what you want to do
a nice societal application of this is
see I'm looking at imagery data I want
to say my task is to predict aging
symptoms of imagery data my facial
images so the problem is
data has these other tricky sensitive
variables of ethnicity gender bla bla
bla bla bla cause you wanna make
decisions based on this so what we can
do is convert these images into a form
that has extremely low information and
trying to predict what the ethnicity or
trying to classify what the gender is
regardless of what algorithm you put on
it because we just taken that
information out it's kind of orthogonal
in terms of how you convertor the
information but it has all the
information to go forward to do your
task which is predict age and the reason
you're doing it is because you have a
job and it's legal that's the reason the
company is doing it anyway so that's a
variable you're safe with got it it's
actually a VR at five minute mark and
before I open up questions for the
audience start thinking what questions I
have one quick question for Abe you know
health care and machine learning so in
particular I'm interested in saying you
know hearing from you how do we convince
the end-user the customer that their
data is going to be dealt with securely
I have a horrible is I'm not sure I
should say on stage which is practically
speaking in US healthcare the consumer
does not really have a seat at the table
right now their data is owned by other
people and actually the thing I'm afraid
of is not that machine learning is not
going to grow by leaps and bounds there
it's that it's going to grow by leaps
and bounds in service of organizations
who are not patients or not the consumer
so I guess this goes back to contracting
and regulation but yeah if you go to a
hospital your data is probably owned
either by that hospital or by the EMR
that the hospital uses and they often
have rights to resell it to others and
it's a little bit of a scary situation
yeah I can't agree more on in a line
data ownership and offloading that
problem is is just saying I take the
elephant at of one room and put it in
your room because you're gonna get tons
and tons of notifications about things
that you don't even know about this
because you've given the ownership and
the permission rights the user itself
that's not a that's not the right way to
solve the problem either can use
blockchain to solve it alright that was
a joke
other questions from the audience do we
have a mic and UN questions
well that's coming up I don't know if
blockchains the solution but regulation
very my wife might be right yeah I don't
know that industry will get there on its
own that's true with the social site
also Facebook's and others similar
problems not much of a difference though
question here yeah test okay is there
like a near term or ongoing discussion
between regulatory bodies in the data
science community over establishing a
crisper definition of why a sufficiently
sophisticated data processing system is
meaningfully different from a human
being reading the data so is the
question around how do you differentiate
between AI reading the data versus a
human reading the data yeah at a certain
point it seems that like a sufficiently
sophisticated processing system we have
these regulations against some external
human sort of reading this data right
and the question is at what point are we
concerned about sufficiently
sophisticated data processing system
having some characteristics that might
approximate those characteristics that
created those regulations firstly got it
actually yeah that's a very valid
question because just the other day I
was reading this news article that you
know Alexa the in order to actually
refine the training of Alexa humans have
to actually hear what's going on and
then they preview a lot of sensitive
information so anyone wants to take this
question I see some interesting
conversation happening in the
journalistic community right there's
investigative journalism
blogging so there's thought work being
done there I don't know how far that's
really penetrated into a regulatory
world I think I don't know like few days
back I saw two senators coming up with
the bill which basically talks about
something very very similar
they basically worried about so the
interesting thing from my experience is
that if you go tell illegal that there
is an human involved in the training and
stuff like that they have less stress
and then say oh my machine learning will
take care of everything so I think there
is this I mean it's it's almost
impossible to do machine learning
without labels to
great extent which is created by humans
so there's a lot of involvement on both
sides I think it's it's gonna be super
hard to because the kind of problem
solved in machine learning is so diverse
that trying to if someone tries to come
up with the regulation like how do they
do the regulation itself is a very
complex thing it's a yeah it's a holy
grail of a Turing machine kind of
question I make a decision I don't tell
you if it's a human-related ation or
like a computer-related ation how are
you gonna distinguish and that's the
Turing test of what you're asking yeah
actually I've got a specific example on
this so at a company I worked for before
we had a specific prediction task that
our doctors is medical company we're
spending a ton of time on they really
didn't like doing the work but they had
to do it it was a crucial process so we
built an engine that we called doc bot
that would predict yeah we took label
training data we just watched what the
doctors did classic human loop problem
and eventually got to the point where we
had 84 percent accuracy on that task and
when I initially took back that back to
the team they said oh this is a medical
task 84 percent accuracy I don't know if
we can live with that
so I went back to our chief medical
officer and I said okay I've got some
new tasks for you to code here we just
need some more training data and I was
lying to him what I was actually doing
is I took the first 500 tasks that he'd
seen already I shuffled them and showed
them to him again so he was just
recoding the same data and he went
through and his agreement with himself
was about 84 7% and I took that back to
the rest of the team I said look
computer 84 human 87 these are close and
everybody said yep yep just turn it over
to the bot yeah a lot on a lighter note
there was a pigeon that was trained in a
academic setting that was able to
classify some of the medical imaging
tasks that people in the machine
learning community boast about in terms
of achieving 99% accuracy what we're
doing is not AI we're doing PG and I and
but it's not artificial intelligence
we're just amplifying the intelligence
of the user that is using the technique
we're nowhere close to AI sure but if
you go back to the Turing test world in
a very limited domain we can pass the
Turing test yeah right you're focusing
on datasets that are too simple and we
are very caning you know
ulterior confidence just by benchmarking
our results on the same thing again and
again it's like a second hackathon on a
very focused thing you need a hackathon
and the real world problems cool so
we're getting into a very lively
discussion law unfortunately at the end
do we have other questions one more here
yeah I think my question applies most to
the split yeah a case but what I'm
hearing is that you in the interest of
privacy you're taking away access to the
raw data from the data scientist but
still giving them a way to do their work
my understanding of a lot of the machine
learning pipelines is you know so much
work goes into the data prep phase where
people have to be doing data cleansing
and there's a lot of assumptions about
the data that need to be true first
before you can make effective use of the
data on the machine learning phase so
what are your thoughts around or what is
the standard around you know I I want to
almost write up a spec these are my
expectations around the data and you
know there are no nulls or the nulls
have been substituted but this and in
the split AI case where different
organizations are working with the data
you need some way to agree I guess like
how the computer understand that the DNA
have met my expectation before I'm gonna
start doing any work with it you've just
set the word expectations like three or
four times there let me put in a plug
for a open source project that I'm
deeply involved on called great
expectations it's focused on exactly
that kind of problem cool awesome
other questions one more Robert
coming at this from the human side again
do you think there's room or reason for
a Hippocratic oath type of thing for
privacy actions on the part of data
scientists for for HIPAA for what
example grata quotas and no I will use
the data yeah it is intended for right
so yeah it's basically it's interesting
you talk about that because when I
talked about the insider threat problem
this is exactly what we had to go
through so it's first thing is kind of
lot of training and to understand like
what they can see and not and then
everybody has to kind of sign an
agreement and things like that I think
it's it is it's the way it is it's
basically like you're kind of putting
your so you it's basically like kind of
regulation and saying that okay data
scientists you are basically aware of
what you are trying to do and this is
like sensitive information and you're
not really allowed to do anything beyond
like what are your work and stuff so we
are to kind of sign an agreement and
saying that okay if accidentally if you
see something and stuff U of T erase it
ahead and things like that it is I mean
I say that's what I was heating into
like regulation this is like a really an
open problem like how do you regulate
these things you know you can get these
signatures from data scientists saying
that you know we wouldn't access do
something which is not we shouldn't be
doing and we know from examples in
facebook and stuff these things happen
so how do you prevent this still in open
problems essentially just reminds you to
avoid obvious mistakes and that's pretty
much well it doesn't that's but that's
that's an important point I said we did
we did implement one of those in every
system that we thought that people
needed access to so every time you log
into the system there'll be the CY that
pops up says hey remember the his
sensitive data and we even think one of
my colleagues says the interesting was
saying
are you comfortable talking about this
with your mom if not then speak to your
privacy privacy champion about whether
this is a problem or not whether you can
share this information that's also yeah
ia percent of data sign
- sir very nice they don't do try to do
things but that one person they were
like oh I this is curious let me try
something yeah I know
yeah it's a question about Hippocratic
oath I think we ought to be moving there
as a community but I also don't believe
that if we sat down together all of us
and tried to write guidelines I don't
believe we're capable of doing that yet
I don't think we have like enough
consensus but I think the thing that
most teams can do is on their immediate
team right now you can write the
equivalent of a Hippocratic oath for
your data team in your in your context
like that's an exercise that basically
everybody could do and I think from a
values perspective most of us want to do
that I think if we do that you know in
500 companies all go through that
exercise then that'll give us enough
kind of raw material to put together a
bigger Hippocratic oath for this
community at large that's my day
[Music]